des scènes comme celle là il y en a eu
toute la semaine à québec de jeunes
immigrants essoufflé mais heureux
surtout fier d'avoir réussi ensemble
même si vous ne parlent pas la même
langue mais tous deux travaillent
ensemble contre les jannati a besoin
mais moi aussi je vous ai tourné pour le
temps semble ces jeunes ont accepté
l'invitation de motivaction jeunesse à
prendre part au challenge polaire un
défi sportif hivernal
une occasion de briller de se dépasser
l'idée d'art le challenge parle c'est
d'offrir une tribune positive aux
nouveaux arrivants de québec
on y ont été vraiment un jour à la fois
un défi à la fois donc chaque jour on
proposait un triathlon 10 km de style 10
km de patin 10 km de ski de fond le
lendemain on a fait la traversée
complète santé lunaire d'art gare
saint-jean avec nos clubs de filles
mardi que l'ouverture du couvre-feu à la
fermeture du couvre feu
on a tenté le plus d'attention de
possibles au mont wright et aujourd'hui
on a fait un grand demi marathon à
travers toute la ville à la rencontre
des classes de francisation
[Applaudissements]
ce challenge c'est aussi frediani 15 ans
originaire de la tanzanie qui a complété
un triathlon de vélo d'hiver de ski de
fond et de course à pied du centre ville
en passant par le parc de la chute
montmorency pour se rendre jusqu'à la
polyvalente de charlesbourg et c'était
bien pour moi aussi pour moi j'étais
juste et ray pour faire il m'a donné un
défi pour moi si je me suis je me suis
fait confiance que je peux le faire et
pour y arriver frais diane s'est inspiré
de l'épreuve qu'elle a vécu alors
qu'elle était dans son pays natal
côté dames op je tombe malade j'ai
failli mourir c'était un défi ça faisait
du bien au coeur parce que je me
rappelle des difficultés j'ai passage de
ma mère et ma famille aussi
sont allés chercher une force qu'ils ont
déjà parce que c'est des gens qui ont
beaucoup de beaucoup d'histoires des
grands des grands parcours university
fait des sportifs sont pas beaucoup de
froid c'est ça que je me moque pays
viennent beaucoup des livres
cette semaine c'était aussi une autre
occasion d'apprivoiser une saison qui
peut paraître au style beaucoup déjà des
énormes
je veux rester à la maison pourquoi je
sors me citer un jeune elle a dû
s'adapter dit je dois les faits pendant
arriver je dois satisfait des montages
et beaucoup d activités d'année aussi
pourquoi en fait est mal fait fermer les
verts même si je l'avais pas vu c'est
pas une saison facile d'ailleurs c'est
la première chose dont tous les jeunes
nous parle dans les premiers chocs
qu'ils arrivent si le français est
l'hiver et c'est pourquoi mettre
l'accent génère son travail fort à
chaque année pour leur donner leur vie
d'aimer cette saison le puis je pense
que le pari est gagné par robert de
belles choses j'ai vu beaucoup de fierté
j'ai vu du dépassement de soi et j'ai
senti beaucoup de joie de vivre et aucun
à l'homme ça fait du bien je pense que
les gens ont besoin en ce moment
ce premier challenge polaire est donc
une réussite sur toute la ligne
malgré les embûches liés à la pandémie
moi je suis très très heureux mamie mue
cette semaine de voir ce qu'ils ont fait
ces jeunes le portier le flambeau de
l'immigration ici à québec le challenge
polaire est là pour demeurer ça c'est
certain
[Musique]